good afternoon councilors staff members
of the public and those joining us on
the live stream welcome to this meeting
of the community well-being committee
um first of all uh we've got apologies
from councilors Bond Campbell and sopa
somebody like to move that they're
accepted
Barry and Grant
put that all in favor against
Carrie
um
we now move to the part of the meeting
where I will hand over to his worship
because it's one of those pleasurable
occasions when we get to welcome on a
new councilor mayor Clark
so this is your chance Steve to be
exposed to the media so if you wanna if
you want to come up the process is
fairly simple a matter of reading you
know and signing your life away so
yeah yeah
[Applause]
it's too late okay
I declare that I will faithfully and
impartially and according to the best of
my skill and judgment execute and
perform in the best interests of the
invercargill city the powers authorities
and duties vested in or imposed upon me
as an elected member of the invercargill
city council by virtue of the Local
Government Act 2002 the local government
official information and meetings act
1987 or any other Act
I wanted
to Welcome to the council and now I have
a two-year and two months okay and no
time
[Applause]
welcome to council Steve
um we do like to give fresh blood an
opportunity to have something to say if
you'd like or if you'd rather not just
get on that's fine as well I don't have
too much to say surprisingly
um I just am feeling very grateful and
very privileged and honored to be here
with you all today I just want to thank
the the public of invercargill that that
voted for me and trusted me with their
one vote that feels really really
special and like a huge honor and to
those uh whose votes I didn't receive I
um and dedicated to this role I will
work hard for all the voices in this
city
um and thank you for the honor of of
serving uh this community
thank you thanks Steve all the best for
the next couple of years and
congratulations on your successful
election
uh there are no matters of public forum
that I'm aware of so we'll move into
receiving the minutes of the community
well-being committee back on July 11th
somebody like to move that they're
received pania and Alex
and he met his Rising
if not I'll put it all in favor against
carried
I'll move we receive the minutes of
District licensing committees July
meetings if somebody would see a
counselor kit thank you
any matters of rising
I'll put the motion then all in favor
against
carried thank you for that
right uh general policies Reserve
management plan
and
Caroline's here along with Jesse would
you like to
come up to the table
welcome come on and join us we've just
blooded him
he's still breathing
good afternoon
um so the first paper that I've got for
you this afternoon is the general
politic Reserve management plan
so this is a paper that we undertook
pre-consultation on last year and it's
an amalgamation of lots of different
management plans that we had held across
the city and what we're asking for now
is for the council to endorse proceeding
to advertise for submissions on what is
now the the full plan for general
policies
um which we will do over a two-month
period for submissions and consultation
period for
um
just to say now we've had those initial
consultation period now to see whether
this is actually what we heard and this
is what the public and the community
wanted to see for their reserves so
we'll cover all reserves across
invercargill other than those that have
got a specific management plan such as
Queen's Park
um Sandy Point management plan those
type of things so it's it's the general
basis for all of our reserves across the
city
thanks here on I guess it's it's a
really good step forward that um
excluding those specific reserves with
their own management plans that we bring
everything else under the one document
because it does simplify things uh we're
really grateful for all those people
that have taken part in pre-consultation
in in some instances they may be a
little confused about why we go out now
but but it was their information that
fed in and set the tone for the document
that we're now putting up for the whole
Community to have its input on so from a
process perspective that's what we're
doing we're also looking for three
councilors
um to be on a panel to hear those
submissions
volunteers
apart for myself
yeah Barry did you take your glasses off
then trash or was it I said
I can do it no it's all right Grant's
volunteered and his worship as well
so worth
um so I think as Mia you can
um participate in any
meeting anyway so the fourth uh
motion is approving
counselors Ludlow Stewart and Dermody
yep
um I'm having a second
moved by councilor Boyle so you can do
by councilor cricket
open for discussion
excellent
that means everybody's Crystal Clear
I'll pop that then all in favor
against
Carrie
it's almost too easy actually all that
work one
um but and moving those things so
quickly I don't want it to to look like
it was just a simple agreement we've had
a favorites discussion on the way
through and we're awaiting um the chance
to to hear what people have to see in
submissions yeah Clark
just in relation to the submissions I
just wanted to call in on a couple of
things
um had the pleasure of going to the uh
blind low vision of building down in
Queens Park recently
um and certainly uh support the request
to keep that facility there not any
suggestion to move it away from
Queensborough
in the past it seems that the previous
regimes management controller that has
been very restrictive on how that
so it can be used but um at the moment
they sometimes contract space out to
other disability groups as well to just
use it for short periods of time which
is something I'd be Keen for us to
continue to do so have some flexibility
there on the issue of the planting more
trees which is one of the submissions
when I first joined Council
it seems like a lifetime ago there was a
a goal by parks and Reserve to plant
50 000 trees I think from memory
basically one for every citizen or every
person in the city and I we sort of got
part way down that track but I just
don't know where we've actually got to
so that's one issue and the final issue
for me is that planting around Sports
field
um
the borders around Sports Fields
especially along waterways which is one
of the submissions I have some major
reservations about that
um having played around some of those
Sports Fields out at otatara when you
have a border that's hidden from the
water itself it creates a safety risk in
its own right
if a soccer ball gets kicked beyond the
tool grass are sitting it by the
waterway and goes behind children will
go looking for the ball but then they're
out of sight
so just wanted to raise that while it's
nice in theory to try and retain the
sports within the field it does create a
barrier that children get lost behind
so just specifically with blind low
vision you can see that they had a
submission in there that we've heard in
pre-consultation from memory that'll
form part of the Queen's back management
plan that they're on yes anyway yeah
um but your other comments are noted
thank you
I can't have any other response you'd
like to read
um I'm more than probably around the
tree planting yeah so the the um the
project that mayor Clark's talking about
is plantar population
um and we haven't completed the plantar
population planting as yet I'll bring an
update through the activity report at
the next meeting okay thank you
any other questions or comments
Delaney did I put the motion great
that moves us on to parks and land
disposal options tab nine oh sorry do we
do tab eight yeah no I don't think we're
here huh we've got a bigger pardon I
have skipped over the parks and reserves
master plan and management plan yep
Caroline
good afternoon Chad
um
what we've done here with this paper is
to be efficient with both Council and
staff time we're seeking Collective
endorsement over the next plans that
we're doing so this is basically our
work plan for the next 12 months on the
um the consultation and the notification
public notifications so you've got a
list of um plans where we've given you
some update updates of where we're up to
on a couple of the plans but also the
ones that we want to do next so that we
are actually coming to you with updates
and Milestones as when we actually reach
different stages within the management
plan consultation process
so
um this is it's pretty much our work
schedule we've prioritized the work
um the master plans and the management
plans based on the dates of
um when the current plans are actually
expiring as it were and so we've worked
out what we've got to do next and then
for our out years as well so you can see
what where we'll where we'll be going to
the public around Reserve management
plans for now and in the future
thank you
so there are three recommendations there
councilor partner yeah just a question
regarding Sandy Point master plan now
the actual
the actual master plan does that go into
the sort of detail of how the area is
used I noticed comments and submissions
about the horse riding and how they get
along with the dog walkers and the
cyclists and everything I mean it's a
brilliant asset out there but
um does that need to be in the master
plan or is that something you just do
separately on an opera on an operational
so the master plan is a high level
document strategy over the next 30 to 50
years and we'll be bringing that back to
yourselves in September so you'll
actually get to see the detail of that
master plan at that point the actually
how we use that land and the more
specifics over the next 10 years they'll
be in the management plan the management
plan that's what I thought so yeah no
it's just a yeah that's separation
that's fine cheers thank you
yeah uh thanks to you just
you've said you've prioritize them
around date
is that the only way you'd prioritize
them like have you gone through the
management plans and thought through
strategically if Sandy Point needs to be
first or something else needs to be
brought up the list yeah that we've
obviously done that at the same time as
well so it's it's they do we do have to
have management plans in place so we've
got the legislative requirement to do
that so we've looked at the date and
then we've looked at what else is going
on around the city to work out where we
would prioritize them based on other
needs as well for example we've
prioritized Queen's Park Town belt to
come in line with when the facilities
are coming in line later on in that time
yeah so we've tried to align them with
other things that are happening
yeah so Ben does um the Surrey Park
master plan fit in with what they're
thinking is around rugby pack
ETS at rugby park as a management plan
area because that sits within the sports
field strategy
councilor cricket
oh thank you Mr chair so my question is
around the regional Sports field
strategy what's the timeline for that
and who's responsible for it at the
moment
so we've got an update on the final
paper I've got today is an update on the
regional recreational strategies so I
can answer it during that paper if you'd
like who like sorry I guess my question
is when we're looking at implementing in
2024 the sports field Omniverse are we
responsible for that as well in
conjunction with it we are responsible
for the invercargill city council
um Sports field strategy yes yeah
the regional the regional we're actually
Fading Into and giving um input into the
regional strategy
let me recalibrate and I'll come back
I'm looking for something specific but
oh yeah me o'clock yeah and section 11
23 which talks about vandalism
um and I see the policies there for them
I'm not sure that they actually um
help us where we need to be there's a
significant amount of damage being done
out at Sandy Point at the moment it's
just
trail bikes and cars doing donuts
absolutely everywhere the whole chunks
of land being chewed up and I'm not sure
any when I read those three full
policies
that lead us to minimized vandalism I'm
not sure we actually get there
I'm not advocating to having a ranger
back out there but we've got to do
something to stop the damages it's
significant and I notice it uh probably
a year ago um Parks planted quite a bit
more vegetation out there and where they
planted that there's no damage so that's
good yeah but I guess you just can't
have the whole area planted wherever you
leave a space there you're going to do
damage so I don't have the answers and
I'm not sure I'm not asking you for the
answer did I just signaling I think
that's a an area of concern we've got no
ears and eyes out there at the moment
and quite a bit of damage being done
I think some of those sex May Clark are
quite simply an act of vandalism oh they
are in it in that case they need to
become a police matter but again that's
a resourcing issue for for police to
deal with as well but there have been
sometimes in the last couple of years
when we've seen significant vehicle
damage
on the road up Sandy Point beside the
sports fields and territory
councilor crackett how are you
or do you still yeah okay Reverend cook
yeah I'll release um councilor cracker
from Missouri for a few minutes
um
just Caroline
in general terms with the master plan
and the management plans
the rethinking that might have to go on
given
um some of the recent
um tree casualties
shall we say and I know I've raised this
before but
I it it is actually alarming me that we
are having more incidences
um and I know that we can't prevent acts
of nature but
I just wonder if um
it is an area of planning and strategy
that
um actually our trees are not actually
aware that we have got a plan and
they're taking the Law into their own
hands and how much does that affect
your planning processes because
you know as I I have commented on the
age and the size of some of those trees
in the past and it doesn't actually
surprise me when they fall over but on
the other hand it's alarming for the
public and how do we get that balance
right because it in some ways it seems
like we're taking out trees well in
nully but in other ways we possibly
could be a little bit more proactive
than we have been so so we do have a
tree plan that was endorsed by Council
in 2020 and that is a plan that we are
following now part of that plan had an
operational aspect to it whereby all of
the trees across the city were assessed
so we actually brought in the arborist
contractors to assess all of them so
we've now got a tree database that tells
us exactly what trees we've got where in
their age and they're
um what do they look what they look like
and we're ensuring that our high risk
trees in amongst that are actually being
assessed more frequently so that was a
one-off assessment to get us going and
we're actually just going out to another
contractor to get an annual assessment
of those high risk ones to give us the
um what required maintenance we we may
need to do some of which may be
proactive
killing of trees so wrapping it from
five yearly to to annually as as a
proactive is it only applying to those
trees stemmed most risky or we're in the
process of identifying which ones those
would be
um other than we're not quite you know
we haven't got that identification of
there will be ones that are in high risk
areas where we've got higher traffic of
people or or vehicles and so those will
be deemed high risk just by nature of
where they are
so we've got a scope we've got to fully
scope that out and find out exactly
which one's the album we will
potentially miss some though obviously
oh and I recognize that it has fiscal
implications for adding that layer of
work yes but on the other hand I guess
there's the health and safety risk of
not doing that work as well absolutely
thank you for that it's a fine balance
thanks you're big and old isn't
necessarily bad
councilor Stewart
the trees that are opposite
um on Ellis Road
they've always been a big worry to me
those ones are big and old we expect
those to be part of our annual
assessment
because if one of those comes down
that'll take quite a few people here
yeah
depending which way it goes councilor
boyleton through each year so the ones
that came down were they on your high
risk
um
uh list so we're just coping that at the
moment we'd had that annual assessment
done and they hadn't been identified in
that annual assessment right so the the
assessment that we'd had done following
on from the tree plan which was a that
yeah so one-off we got all of them as um
identified
they weren't identified as ones that
would come down especially that's what I
thought yeah so it's a bit of a worry
isn't it because I mean we can't you
know advocate for all of the trees but
you know obviously if they come down
areas and they're not high risk it means
you're not getting that second
assessment of those are you
some trees you can't assess from The
Outsiders no no I know that right yeah
it's a good point yeah I think it's
worth recognizing that
um sometimes the new extremes and
weather events and rainfall can can
cause variances and what would observed
previously yeah councilor pottinger yeah
thank you chair just still on the tree
subject
um
root shallowness is that something your
Tree Experts can determine or is that a
bit of a mystery because obviously the
age doesn't need to be old for you know
a tree with shallow roots get blown over
no it's not something that our
assessments generally cover
right so that's the
Darkness it's got to be a visual yeah
it's going to be visual to say so
without digging down you can't see no
you can't allow just relating back to my
golf courses the same thing trees fall
down and they don't look that bigger
role like the ones Barry we're talking
about and without knowing that root
structure
yeah you could be taking out good trees
but you could be taking out yeah yeah no
no it's a tough one so good luck yeah
just making sure that we're on point
with the master plans and management
plans getting into some of the lighter
stuff councilor cracker do you oh I'll
ask my question as part of the sports
field that's okay
that's okay okay councilor durman all
right dive into it yeah just going back
to the trees
um and to pick up on Trisha's Point
um
in in bearish sort of linking the two so
you would think that a tree that has the
potential
to put the public at risk would be
assist
um in more detail
as opposed to a tree that you know has a
less Russell on ring is golf course
there's probably a lesser risk than
potential those trees falling over down
on
Ellis Road
that's right yeah so yeah
you're not giving me confidence that
actually a tree assessment is actually
so that's what we're scoping at the
moment Council Derby we're actually
scoping to ensure that we have covered
off those high risk trees in those high
risk areas that's what we're currently
ensuring that we have got that in place
the tree plan covered an assessment of
all trees as a one-off we're actually
scoping to do that annually now in in a
different manner on those high risk
areas and so that'll include the
underground assessment you can't do that
well you can do it for floodplain so how
can you not do it Patrice
yeah I can't have an arborist assessment
underground Albus assessed the truth
well maybe it's not an average we're
using and you know because it is a risk
and it's probably something we should
have on order wrestling around that
public risk Steve
yeah look I think um councilors raised a
really good point I think Caroline has
identified that the criteria that we're
going to look at the assessment of these
trees is going to take a location and a
place-based approach
um and there are certain areas that you
just can't anticipate but we'll do that
on a risk basis so where there are lots
of people we will definitely identify
and undertake an assessment as much as
the team can to give confidence
um and so I think we've taken the point
and the team will take that feedback on
board
me Clark
um you're just going to raise one issue
which was raised by um one of the
submitted which is around the ability to
Freedom Camp
and it doesn't seem to me as though we
have any space with that allows for that
and the submission talked about
um
being self-contained but the problem
with that is that you can get a
self-containment sticker online for
nothing and just slap it on the back of
your vehicle without having any other
required touring things and required but
it just seems to me that we should have
some space designated space where people
can throw a tent up if they want to and
ideally it'll be close to a toilet block
so they're not having that sort of
ongoing problem because the moment the
only options seem to be you go to a a
private
uh camping ground
or alternative you're in the association
that's got the one down by State Street
Wharf
but there are other people that want to
travel around New Zealand for our team
don't stay a couple nights I guess
that's where do you place the priority
with those private camping grounds for a
rate payers yep or temporary two or
three day visitors to town who
contribute very little because we've had
some pretty vociferous submissions from
those rate paying camping grounds in the
past but again this conformed part of
what people are able to uh to speak to
in the submission process
any other points that anybody wishes to
raise
okay could I get a uh somebody to move
for three recommendations
Reverend Clark and councilor Boyle
nothing else if you confused us
sorry Reverend Cox starts with a C
I used to do the uh the same thing with
um
mayor Clark when he was a counselor yeah
with his wife so I've managed to saw
them
oh there we go now I can see
my apologies Reverend cook
thank you
second to uh councilman Boyle I'll put
that all in favor against
carried
this time on to tear oh sorry
um I neglected uh
item five which is uh accepting uh major
lake item which is the minutes of the
community well-being fund appointments
it was held uh back on Monday third
August there is uh and in public and
public excluded item around that put
some alert to move that we accept those
as late items and meetings were only
held last week
I'll put that all in favor against
Carrie thank you for your Indulgence
parks and land disposal options while
you're there
so the paper in front of you summarizes
the review of land that was undertaken
as part of our ongoing process to ensure
that we're efficient and effective
across the land that we manage and we've
got three types of land that we've
updated in this paper one where there's
been prior approval given in previous
processes to the land for to be disposed
an inclusion of new Parcels of land to
review and endorse or otherwise and the
exclusion of some previously raised
pieces of land
um that under review have become very
strategic we've obviously given the
follow the criteria and agreed Criterion
and notified whether the land is
strategic or non-strategic
and also put in in our analysis a report
around carbon sequestration and the
opportunity to to look at that as an
option
and
provided you with
hopefully an update which covers all of
the areas which we've previously looked
at in some cases over quite a few years
councilor councilor Dermody mayor Clark
look my questions around and like and
appreciate the work that's done here and
enlisting what potentially could be sold
but if if the buyer of the land
um it's zoned Reserve at the moment
what zoning uh is it after he buys it
and does he have to go through uh the
RMA to utilize the yet and the land for
another obviously use outside of the
reserves
what what's how yeah sorry didn't quite
Chris then Jonathan
well Jonathan then Chris
yeah
um so through you chair uh it so the
reserve sits as a layer
um which is a current layer and then it
takes on so the land takes on the zoning
around it so that needs to be determined
because obviously it will vary according
to where the parcel of lend is that's in
discussion
okay so if someone wanted to use a piece
of land for Real Estate say go Donovan
for example
and that they still would have to go
through all the hard work of of perhaps
getting it zoned even though it is near
a real estate you know housing area
there's no guarantee is there yeah
that's correct
right
through YouTube but we would change it
first with me before we sold it well
that would depend entirely on what the
buyer needed that's I just you know that
was the bit of the loophole so that that
is possibly an opportunity that any
developer might have to absorb as would
happen anywhere else when somebody was
seeking to change the zoning of a land
for the activity that they required it's
not up to us to change it first
this is the start of the land disposal
policy and so the first part of that is
really getting that Community voice into
each of these Parcels of land so once
that we have that full assessment right
and we do further analysis yeah this
part of the land disposal process is the
revocation of Reserve status and that's
further down the process than where we
are now so you've seen in
one of the parcels that we're updating
we're actually at that point
but for the majority of these Parcels of
land we're just reaching out to the
community really trying to get that
Community voice against those parts the
reason that I sort of went for it was
the question is that you've got
valuations there and of course if you
value it for building houses on then
it's worth x amount there but you can't
build houses on it
and then it's not worth x amount so I
just wondered how you arrived at your
valuations
so the evaluations for the QV valuations
at 2020 which were the most up-to-date
evaluations at the time but how yeah I
just wanted so the valuations can only
be done on their current status yeah
they can't be speculative that's right
record evaluation yeah so it's valued at
a reserve as a reserve
okay
Council of Germany yeah um a couple of
things obviously this is of course a bit
of consternation in the community and so
just wondering whether
um you know using land disposal as part
of sort of what we're doing sort of is a
bit preemptive when really what we're
doing is we're going to the community
consult around what's the best use
from the community so that's just a sort
of a comment but
and also around your strategic asset
thing in particularly around Bluff
um you know it's classified as a
non-strategic asset but I'm not sure the
bluff community's had input into that
classification and they might have a
different view on that
and I think that's an important Gap in
the in the process because
um
you know that's a very good example
where you know that would be considered
probably a strategic asset to the bluff
Community but we've classified as normal
strategic so again we've we're being
preemptive
and I think we just need to
listen to some of the feedback we've had
um and and think through how we learn
these proposals in the in the um in the
public and how we classify things and we
give consideration to community
thought and need
any feedback on that Carolina Chris
or is it just coming it's just a comment
okay thank you uh I've got Mia Clark
been canceled at Cricket so I've got a
range of issues here Carolina just want
to clarify again that if we wanted to
sell a current Reserve we wouldn't sell
it as a reserve would we we would change
the status to sell it we would have to
revocate the research status on that's
what I wanted we all wanted to know
um so I guess I've got a range of
questions on the papers so just be with
me as I've worn them away through the
criteria that you've got the priority
criteria they've got in the earlier
Pages you've got eight of them there one
of the gaps in that seems to be the
issue of uh not necessarily selling but
getting into a joint venture with a
developer
which four argument site might allow us
to somehow gift the land and some
infrastructure cost to a joint venture
partner in return for us then achieving
some of the units that they built which
is a little bit outside the square but
some councils are going down that track
now
um
which um and and that criteria doesn't
doesn't quite cover that and it tends to
only focus on on social housing which is
not an area that we are targeting at the
moment
you know targeting aged care
um it's our priority so just wanted to
flag that
and the other issue which I think
my colleagues raised which was the
estimated value for the 37 hectares
added
Donovan Park uh I guess it's it's
helpful if we're disposing of land to
house
have a potential
I guess
um costing that what we might get for it
as well because this the whatever the
number we've got there 670 000 I think
it is
um
I mean I I've had somebody approach me
this to say that they would be
interested in five hectares and prepare
to pay six million dollars out of
Donovan Park so that tells me that
parceland is probably worth 30 million
dollars
um so that's a significant eye-watering
amount and it might change the
um views of some people in the public as
well as we sort of show that we can
dispose of land that we've got no real
need for at the moment
and that that sort of money allows us to
do a whole lot of other things that the
community would want us to do that's not
necessarily in the in the Parks and
reserves area so that's I guess that's
why certainly the other issue was that
you've got on your report there uh it
says Donovan Park part
so what does the part mean does that
mean that the what's potentially for
sale is the is the part that's not there
is that the piece in the middle it's got
the a couple of ponds on it with the
with the bird models and stuff that you
can actually drive through is that is
that absent from it so in the appendix
it's got the
um I've seen there the graphic so the
yellow is the graphic that's the part
so the other part that's not within the
yellow is not not part of the proposal
okay
you know that's fine thank you I think
before I go to councilor Cricket it's
worth pointing out that from an Aramaic
process we can revoke
a reserve status but that doesn't
change
personing yeah
which is a different process which is
something that the applicant needs to go
through so there is a difference we can
unregister it as a reserve but it still
doesn't necessarily mean that whatever
is planned for that space is is an
easily permitted activity not to say
that it can't be overcome just just
point on it through your chief
and I've had some feedback on that issue
recently from some developers that are
Keen to develop and they say they will
have a very specific perspective though
the other hand but it's a very balanced
one that so can disagree some councils
have used a notified
resource consent prior to the actual
District plan being changed itself and
that that's set okay with it with the
process
which means that because it seems to me
that the district plan change I mean
like I said it's not insurmountable yeah
but there's just there is a process to
to go through we do the first part it is
up to the applicant to go through the
zika bar I'm not saying that it can't be
done I'm just saying it's not
once we remove the reserve status a slam
dunk there's a relatively simple process
that everybody has to go through I think
if there are specific proposals coming
up
we might want to stop here before we
compromise ourselves yes indeed I wasn't
suggesting that what I was leading to
was the um issue that we have some
fairly urgent leave that some housing
upgrade both in volume and then quality
of housing that we have in the city
certainly in South City
um and we have um potential Economic
Development coming our way and we've got
developers who want to get into
retirement villages as well and what
seems to block all this seems to be our
district plan and availability of land
so I guess what I'm signaling is that's
probably our priority is to and while we
might want to free up land is to also do
some work around the district plan as
well
yep but also having spent 20 years
dealing with such things a developer
will have a very specific perspective
that they are looking for the easiest
most cost efficient way forward
again I'm not saying that it can't be
done
but all I've got to do is follow the
process if in some cases they're
expecting us to to do everything that's
not necessarily in the right pair's
interest
councilor Cricket then councilor Boyle
and I'm sure it's a very quick answer to
this as well so the mocha Boko Reserve
in the two three one Scott
Street Road they're both Lane locked and
I can see that there's the appendix
there what happens if they don't sell
we just keep them it's not like we just
have to
because they're yeah like
the conditions are that the person must
take over the land that from an
adjoining property is it right and it's
landlocked so if none of the current
neighbors want to buy that that's just
going to sit stagnant and we still pay
for it regardless
yeah
uh it's councilman Boyle doing Ribbon
cook seems to me that what um the mayor
says about the uh opportunity to um sell
this piece of land or sell whatever
perhaps we could prioritize that in
terms of looking at this I'm not saying
it it would
um follow any incorrect process but we
probably could get on to it earlier
rather than later
consideration
noted
Reverend cook
um so a couple of things am I incorrect
all correct and thinking that 794 Queens
Drive has previously been before us and
we decided to sell or
um there's another Council but but yes
oh yes sorry
but we have looked at this before yes
now did the process not work or did we
back away from it we didn't follow
through okay thank you for that
um the other thing was that changing
um
some of this land that was in reserve
status
is
um
potentially
I'm trying to think of a way to say this
um
they've previously been School sites and
things like that are they subject to the
NATO claim Settlement Act
um
that will be the next stage
um Evelyn to actually be able to
identify each of those individual pieces
of land if we look at that there are I
couldn't I haven't got the detail in
front of me but some of the pieces of
land if they are deemed crownland that
could well be the case okay so
I would have to say that potentially
it's an interest for me and that so that
my fellow counselors are a fellow table
members are aware that that is something
that we will be observing with some
interest
it is with noting River and cook that
the specific site at sarri pack was in
city council ownership before it was
commandeered by the Ministry of
Education so that that doesn't apply but
create an interesting little roundabout
as well yeah
but for the others yeah absolutely I'm
not sure how Moe will resolve that one
yet but
and I suppose that there that follows on
then that if they're currently in a
reserve status is it easier to transfer
them to another type of Reserve than it
is to to
um turn them into Freehold or am I
getting far too technical for this for
this table too
you could
I'm not sure that we can answer that no
I was looking around and I'm thinking
seduce of experts in that particular
question
I think except for you
in my way would have a definite process
for doing this
so they'll be able to In terms
show what's happened in other places I
would disagree I've watched Ministry of
Health over land that used to belong to
the city on the Green Belt where the old
um nursing home uh it's not not nursing
in the old hospital site was down next
to McDonald's
um and they simply claimed Nova's hours
so you know that that may well be what
Moe try and do as well we don't know
um but it's something that when we get
down that pathway we'd have to have that
discussion yes to see how they respond
there's potentially three blocks in in
this one so yeah yeah thank you
thank you Council of Germany yeah just
to reinforce The Miz point about one
thing we do need to get more accurate
inside into the potential value if the
it has changed because that would impact
on decision making
around an equally
um and I know with some of the schemes
that the government has talked about in
future governments are talking about
potentially is that you know that
in a fake public private Partnership if
we have the right value on our land we
are putting significantly more Capital
into a project and probably putting all
the capital we need to to get the
outcome for our community around some
housing so you know the values do become
really important and I know there's a
process around
you know there's still some steps to get
to the point where they become that
realized value right that but valuers
would still assess that on that
presumption so you could be clear on
everything going equal this is where you
land I think that's really important
part we need to take account here and
and it's not like we haven't done that
before we are a real block of land when
it was Zone rural for example was it x
value but what council was able to show
as if it was rezoned Industrial
um what its increased value would be but
what we haven't done to this point is
actually go to the values and ask them
that question we'd want to make a bit
more of it than we did there
well it depends on what we do after we
make the the zone change
and Council got involved uh councilor
correct then me clay
um thank you Mr chair I just I guess I'm
just a way that's sensitive about
hearing things like public-private
partnership and rezoning and you know
consenting and such because I really
don't want us to get into a sticky
situation where we're almost precluding
what could happen with that parcel of
land
I think it's really important to enter
conversations and stuff but it's really
important that we remain completely
non-biased about what happens to that
when it comes to developing
I think we're open we're just looking at
what the possibilities are Mia Clarke
just as a response to there
um
it's okay to say that but once the
land's gone the land's gone and and
sometimes we only have two other sources
of
um building units that we need or
building houses that we need
um that um that don't hit the right
player's pocket and that central
government and we've tried that angle
still some options there but um
certainly if the private sector want to
get into into an arrangement with us as
they have in the Hastings area where
they've got ewe uh local developers
Government funding and local government
funding those sort of joint ventures
actually end up being very good results
and very cost effective as well
um just one other point for you chair
was the issue that Chris raised is
whether the um the Donovan Park one
which has some urgency for me because
I've got uh potential for development
there which I think is in our interest
it's currently sitting on a time frame
of 18 to 24 months and just want to know
from staff where it's possible that
could slide up into the green area which
is a a much shorter time frame of six to
12 months whether they could work on
that
because I like that that parcel land
excuse me open some options for us to
achieve the housing outcomes that we've
been striving for for probably two
decades
so through each year I think Nick luck
so the ability to Fast Track Parcels of
land will have an impact on other work
that we have previously prioritized sure
so we would need to come back here to
Define the impact on Fast tracking any
of that work
yes we could I guess all I'm trying
trying to tell you is or let you know is
that our biggest need that we've got in
a city and have been for two decades is
to improve the level of housing we've
got and we just seem to get up against
roadblocks but we've got some real
potential in that in that block now so
we're actually jumping way down the
track and launching dangerous territory
here so it is to answer the mayor's
question it is possible to have that
fast tracked
but first of all we need to get more
information and a report from staff on
the costs and effects of that doesn't
say it can't be done there's just that
process that we have to go through first
councilor pottinger and then Mrs Coop
thank you chair
um look where does where do we sit with
our spatial plan and when we're going to
be revising that because obviously the
spatial plan
give us an overview a spatial plan has
no standing as far as the district plan
is it was called a spatial plan but it
isn't one well it's a guideline it was a
guideline for the district plan it is
not a spatial plan under the current
definition of spatial plans okay so what
plan do you want to call I've heard
people call it a spatial plan and that
wasn't very good
[Laughter]
so the spatial plan I'll say it again
the spatial plan was simply a starting
doctor okay plan can I finish yeah thank
you from which we started the district
plan review that's all it was it said it
was like pre-consultation
okay so what plan
gives an overview of where we are
looking at Future housing because every
city in New Zealand must have
a a forecast of where they want to
expand which areas so what okay it
doesn't so currently the district plan
but you're able to review that at any
point okay I'm just wondering how that
aligns with what we're trying to do here
in disposing land because obviously
there's some critical parts of land and
I'm wondering where do they sit in our
current District plan
to what we want to do to what our city
so if if you're leaning in towards the
area that I'm
trying to Veer things away from it
doesn't sit there but that's not to say
that Council can't go and review the
district plan is only what it is because
that's as far as we've taken it if
Council wants to go and review a part of
it and where we've zoned uh land it can
do that at any stage with partial plan
reviews so no that's fine that's what
I'm trying but there is no there is no
spatial plan there is no long-term plan
beyond what sits in the district yeah
I'm just trying to see what Vision we
have that will allow us
to be flexible
and now and whatever plan it may be
flexibility is a subjective thing there
counselor oh absolutely I've got you
there
so again I'll say it's it's we can we
can do anything we just need to run the
process first so we have what we have
because it's there at the moment if you
want to review it that's fine
I'm wondering what part of that's
missing
we just need to go through a review of
of zonings if that's what you want to do
but to do that
much like
um changing what we we give value will
have to rearrange your work schedule can
be done absolutely and if that's where
Council places its priority we will do
it
I'm just the only reason I raised it
because what we have here today is a
trigger because this land wasn't going
for sale
10 days ago or whatever but it is now so
or how long ago whatever it's not for
sale no no but it wasn't proposed so
that's what I'm saying it's a trigger
the only trigger is this conversation
okay no no I think we've ended our
conversation chair well I've tried we've
got councilor Boyle
no I don't have anything sorry Mrs Coop
my apologies
I just want to agree with the mayor that
we actually do need to free up some land
for development and for housing so
totally we seriously need to look at
that
um I think the ones that you've
identified in blood with the we've been
down the road I think with the ward
reserve on sillustration and the and the
bluff Hill bit of Reserve there is
I think they have really good areas the
person I'm confused about and I think
the bluff Community was a wee bit was it
around the camping ground and
understanding that it's it's on Council
land and Council doesn't run camping
grounds
um yeah I think it just yeah there's
just a wee bit of sensitivity which you
would have noticed guys right so that's
how how we work through through that as
a given that it's probably a community
type
place it's um been well supported you
know and we and we have a high number of
tourists so
that's probably my thinking on that
okay thanks for the comment
I guess by way of reassurance and and
where some of the conversations being
leading if there is an appetite at
Council for a review
of of some of the zonings to
help look at what can be done to rezone
for residential there is something
counselor can do and and it can can run
through that but
there was no
plan for that
fine if if that's where there's an
appetite fine we can we can look down
that path but we've got to be really
careful about getting into specifics at
this stage yeah
because the further the conversation
goes please hear this
the more expensive it's going to become
if we can't handle it with our own
hearings panel yeah yeah yes
and and that's what I'm trying to say
be very careful
I just have one other question is it a
question is it a question because the
question is the other piece I forgot to
um so I just asked about Jonathan Park
so that whole piece that's sort of like
being split out an aerial thing
um I'm just aware that
um to tapatane was here
recently around
the other shank piece which is an issue
involved in this whole piece and wasn't
in the beginning
um
given that that's a big change of a
reserve
so if there was any future
what would that look like if that other
piece was cut off it at some stage I
mean then you have really no Reserve
when you're looking at Donovan Park
making a duck pond and a Rugby field
I'm not sure that we can answer that a
proposal came in front of council a
decision was made I'm not sure how much
further we can take it in this proposal
came forward again
foreign
we dealt with it if there's another
proposal that comes forward that's fine
we'll deal with that then there's
nothing else that we can do at this
point
any further questions
okay mayor Clark sorry so just some
reflection to that Barney I think one of
the issues that we discussed last time
and I won't be breaching too much
confidentially about talking about this
is that if you rezone a land
um it doesn't give a current tenant for
one for better words an automatic right
to that land so for items like if you
had a piece of land and somebody's doing
some work on it and they'd like to buy
it for a million dollars but once you
rezone it into industrial residential
somebody comes along and says I'll give
you six million dollars for that we'd be
hard pushed to then sell it for a
million dollars
and that was the risk I think that we
that we faced last time we made the
decision
okay it probably still is
questions comments
okay there are four recommendations
there I'm looking for remover
is that a was that a Todd's auction
moment treasure were you pointing at
something no just just move councilor
Stewart seconded councilor Derby put
that all in favor against Kerry thank
you for the discussion there
uh brings us to the update on Regional
Recreation strategies
um
good afternoon chair
um so this is an update on the regional
recreational strategies it's for certain
Sports World strategy and the Southland
Regional Regional spaces and places
strategy
um so the regional Sports field strategy
has been reviewed and we have
um received it it was a bandage to this
document and both of those strategies
have got a guide in planning principles
which are listed there under
recommendation three
and we're hoping that you will endorse
us moving forward to having an
invercargill city council Sports field
management plan for 2013 which we will
then review which will take on board the
guiding planning planning principles
that we've received from these Regional
strategies
the original spaces and places strategy
which was
um originated in 2021 has been uh is on
in the process being reviewed and will
hopefully be completed by the end of
this year
and all of these new strategies are
basically giving us a more informed view
across the region and therefore enabling
us to have a more informed view locally
within invercargill on out what our
strategies likely look like whilst also
keeping that Regional overview with our
um nearby communities
so just bearing them on the regional
Sports field strategy was expected to be
formalized by the end of July and it's
now August how far away
just we received it in between
yeah I've got a timeline for the process
what's the next stage we've received it
we've received it we've received it it's
um and it forms part of our review
review 's report yeah thank you sorry
for my
okay counselors
there are four recommendations here
sorry six
for someone to move them
I'm happy to move them to you councilor
cracker seconded
Mrs poot
let's open for comment
councilor correction thank you
um
has this gone to a Gore in Southland as
well
The Wider review has it gone to gore
description yeah I don't think it's
actually gone to their councils yet but
they um will commit the officers have
them to do uh this process with
internally as they you know as they want
to yeah so everyone is on the same that
same page in terms of like they'll be
implementing we're all at the same state
management planes as well for their own
respective spaces and places I haven't
had that update and turned on each what
each Council are doing but this is now
available for us to use the same
planning principles of across the region
so where they're when their strategies
are up for Renewal I would expect that
that would be they would be doing the
same yes so it's part of these
conversations
um you know like it's
for a better context obviously it's been
about
um how we will fund these our own spaces
and places in future but also how local
community funders will feed into when
they get their requests for funding as
well so have they been part of the
conversations of the overarching
um Sports field strategies
or will they get the master plan
documents they're absolutely been part
of those the working groups that have
formed these strategies yeah
yeah the councils and the funders have
all been part of those working groups
yeah I guess the part I'm trying to pin
down is what when it comes to sitting
down um and making your decisions around
what we will fund and what what we won't
perhaps even as part of part of our
community well-being fund committee
um
you know we've had recently a couple of
requests for funding for particular
pieces of infrastructure this kind of
piece of strategic work and those Master
plans will help them form those
decisions psychees from a funders
perspective
which win along in the process will they
get the final documents and which one
are we expecting that they'll be working
off will it be the Strategic document or
will it be the actual master plan of
what will be
the Strategic document the regional
strategic document if uh if so endorsed
by the committee is what we'll be using
to ensure that our our documents have
got the same planning principles so they
will be consistent across the entire
region yeah
straight
yeah um thank you I think Carolyn's
answered it
um in terms of a regional level but but
the other expectation is that we have as
Council officers is that within the
invercargill city boundaries we will
also be engaging with our funders on our
localized plans as well and looking at
the way in which we progress that
through our long-term planning process
so there is a plan to look at our
regional facility assets that sit with
the number cargo as well
thank you
really mindful
that the sports use waxes and wanes
[Music]
um
does does subcomment and hear about you
know
um
almost encouraging people to use certain
areas more intensively perhaps that
might be the wrong way to say it but
there was talk about the the
um
the artificial turf and the use of that
over over different periods of times and
things like that
but looking at her Sports grounds as a
whole
how much flexibility is there if there
is an up-and-coming sport that we don't
currently know about but may want to
be active in the city
is there the capacity
with any other facilities now and
or are we at a point where we're sort of
saying if you're not this there's no
room for you
um or you'll have to find your own place
or whatever I mean
I'm watching this with a Fascination I
no longer do any of these things and I
don't have children or grandchildren who
do these things but I'm wondering just
um
you know you see other sports pop happen
and all of a sudden they're the flavor
of the month do we have the capacity do
we have some flexible spaces where those
things could could actually become a
sport or
or become a competitive sort of
that don't need buildings or
infrastructure but they need a space if
we got that
I think what we've got is um we've got a
flexibility within our current Sports
field areas and a lot of what these
strategies are doing is actually looking
at
what we perhaps initially had and what
we've currently got and trying to look
at those future long-term trends of the
population to understand where the
flexibility is needed it's not
um I probably can't give you a sport
specific answer without no of the sport
specific question but absolutely I would
say that we we appear to have that
flexibility in what we've currently got
um and we're just trying to to manage it
so that we retain that flexibility
across all sports
this one was one of these the strategy
Sports field strategies looked at
rectangular Sports though
right because I noticed in the comment
that came up much earlier in the there
was some comment about the general plans
about
um is no longer much in the way of horse
riding trails and and the flexibility
for that and have we actually planned
all our things so far that you have to
go out to Sandy Point to be able to to
do Trail horse riding safely
um and then they're raising the conflict
there so it's sort of inspired me to
think that there must be some sports
that are not compatible with others but
also there might be some sports that
could be tucked into where somebody else
actually is more active but it's not
feel fully utilized and this is going to
cover some of that
maintain that flexibility and I'm not
aware of us not achieving it in our own
spaces at the moment and we just as I
say because these strategies are based
on population Trends we're hoping that
we'll manage it in the future as well
thank you for that okay so I've got
councilor Dermody Mrs coat then
councilor Boyle Grant yeah thanks cheers
so when you commission the report
um what were you expecting to get out of
it
um I might take that one cancel it
through your chair uh active Southland
commissioned us
um with the support of the three
councils and the funders and the aim was
to address Regional demand
um for the green spaces that we're
currently managing and to get a picture
regionally but then to help inform our
localized planning
so it's done the first part which is to
identify Regional demand where we're
well served and where there's enough
space and it's then for the local
councils to each then take and undertake
their own reviews and to implement that
through the management plans that
they've got through their respective
areas yeah okay yeah so secondary
um
oh I probably was thinking that it would
might come up with some stuff around how
we would combine as a region to fund
facilities like
um the uh
you know Stadium potentially a regional
part where we'll meet up a wider a
national need from a regional
perspective but it obviously it's
different in terms of reference yeah
that the scope was very much about
enabling and continuing participation it
didn't address the underlying funding
issue yeah uh that a number of our
regional facilities have yeah which set
majority in invercargill so so will that
be something that will come next I think
that's something through the long-term
plan process that we'll be looking at
through our uh Sport and recreation
facility overview but from a regional
perspective though we will take a
regional guidance better be a number
cargo specific strategy yeah
yeah so we can't force
the feedback you hear from funders is
that they would like to see a regional
strategy for some of their region
National facilities based regionally
right
yeah what I'm saying is it's hard to get
the other councils to commit their money
to it though uh and I I guess if you
look at some areas where you've got
those Regional facilities they're being
administered by a Regional Council which
does operate across the boundaries of
the various Tas and that would be
advantageous but look to be honest I
can't see much changing in the in the
short term it depends on The Bravery of
the discussions between the the
territorial authorities locally I think
there are you know there's good sense in
it and we can all see that and there's
some opportunities to protect uh special
facilities exist in areas outside
um our boundary as well as what we've
got within the city district as well so
yeah long term yeah I think it's
something we should aim to but it might
be one of those things that it could be
useful if the funders uh joined in and
applying pressure to those councils as
well to to make them worry of the worth
of that type of strategy yeah so this is
only really to inform us isn't it
which is unfortunate yeah
Tanya a really good um Step shot
but um for me I just got left hanging
when I you know
we just left it in the strategy
I mean
yeah how do our grounds
they were part of the yeah it was
mentioned absolutely part of the overall
assessment yeah
councilor Boyle I think this is amazing
to get to this point I know what's gone
on before
um if we're looking at flexibility
you've only got to look at how frisbee
golf has worked with the golf so that's
brought a different sport but used an
existing facility very very successfully
so I think that as a council we should
stand strong about the facilities that
we have got and look at multi-purpose
use
it takes a change of thinking in some
instances because when this golf South
came forward to healthy families with
the concept for for a disc golf course
packs at that point wanted to shift it
to other Penny
um that was very quickly pointed out
that the stream there is not conducive
to people
keeping their discs which come at a cost
um
but you're right it's one of those
things where it's proven to be a bigger
hit than many people expected but it
also reflects the changing trend of
people to participate in more casual
sport rather than organized team sports
and that's the stuff we're getting
through from sport New Zealand as well
and and active Southland
just as a final word I think um if you
don't mind I think that this like this
piece of work is extremely important I
think that we shouldn't lose sight of
the fact that having this really
comprehensive data that we actually
haven't had before to inform our
decision
is actually really important that Sports
New Zealand has highlighted that um and
it is very true that Regional and Simon
Regional local councils local government
is the primary funder of all Recreation
um and play spaces Sports spaces across
New Zealand by like
an overwhelming percentage so it's yeah
like it's absolutely Paramount that we
have this information to move forward
with
thank you councilors there are six
recommendations
somebody prepared to move them
councilman Germany seconded councilor
cracker
are there any further questions or
comments
thanks a discussion I'll put the vote
all in favor aye against
carried
that brings us through to the activities
report thanks guys or I'll let you go
now
um uh is there anything specific in
there that anybody wishes to raise
um just on the issue of Russell Square
playground development
um it is a statement is a toilet has
been programmed for it to be installed
over the next couple of years through
the long-term plan look we've been
talking about this for two or three
years at least I had inquiries and I was
definitely a minute a couple of years
ago and gave a commitment to be done
within two years we'll win it up to that
period now and we still don't have that
I just don't understand why a toilet and
such a a heavily populated area isn't a
priority for us it doesn't take two
years on a long-term plan to get a
toilet and if you ever go through there
through something you'll see the amount
of volume that's there I just think we
should just get on and get it done
we had some very interesting feedback
along those lines at nahuifa but I
recently when we were doing some Mata
Walker consultation and and
um I pointed out that there was a public
toilet we'd put in down in southern
Chicago but they correctly responded
with yeah but that's across a major road
and if you've got kids playing in the
Russell square area it's not a deal
great point and I think it's been picked
up by um Parks as well
uh any other items within the activities
report that anybody which is the race
Council of Germany yep I love my traps
um so
um just question
um
the the track counters that are me out
there and I think that's a really good
way of sort of measuring it is that just
measuring foot traffic or is it
measuring other users as well
yeah
um so the the track counters there are
um
ah they're a laser counter yeah they can
they count that's Fortress it's just
whatever whatever breaks the beam if you
think of it like that it's whatever
breaks the beam on the way past
so a low-flying kitaru for example or a
spider or something sitting by them they
they are there's something we manage
bike absolutely it could be Caroline
with her four dogs five dogs Lord help
me all Leaf okay that's good thanks the
second question is then um you know the
numbers do drop over off over winter but
hell
if we hit more all-weather tracks or
Aria tracks uh some tracks
you know better used in winter time like
how well were we cating for winter
basically I'm trying to understand and
if we invested some more we get more use
which is great for mental health and
wellness and all that good stuff so I'm
just trying to understand should we put
a little bit more money in to get better
use or do you think we're about right
and it's just emotion and I think it's
where the dependency is so the track's
underfoot we're not I don't receive a
lot of feedback on the actual whether
they're wet and muddy or unable to be
passed so it's usually whether people
are happy to be out in whatever weather
is out there so that's the way that's
not the foot ground yeah the yeah the
tracks themselves are in pretty good
condition
thank you
any further questions on the activities
report councilor Craig my apology
um thank you I'm not a question but I
believe it was councilor doomedy last
activities report requested um
information about the demographics
around whether or not we're reaching
young people when our Communications
um and I see that it's been provided in
this report so they've split the age and
gender and sort of showed us that it's
you know quite a minimal portion of 18
to 24 year olds that are actually seeing
our
um Facebook so I think it was really
important and quite reflective that
they've put in the bit about the
libraries Tech talk in the Chicago city
council Tick Tock Pages because I know
that um in other areas across the
country that have been really successful
with targeting those demographics of
using um
funny memes really but funny but
appropriate names
um yeah so I thought that also useful
commentary in there about the fact the
more accepted a form of social media
becomes by the mainstream the less
appeal it has to the young people that's
right yeah they move Facebook was cool
until your parents were on it yeah yeah
that's right
two
follow up to that though and looking at
the age and gender demographics about
host reading
or accessing a media is that something
we need to be concerned about as well
because I mean
it would appear
that we are actually
um apart from the 18 to 24 year olds we
are really not reaching out to men as
well as we are to women and I don't know
the answer to that because I'm obviously
not the gender that's not responding but
is is it something that we need to
actually look at how we word things so
more pictures and food
facetious I apologize councilman cracker
I just might just remind that
representation of social media specific
points it's not a actual reflection of
all of our marketing or Communications
touch points I'd imagine that the
penetration of the emails that we send
posters advertising other Myriad of
other channels but I'm sure if Lisa is
hiding around the corner somewhere
should be able to hardly hiding so there
was a microphone ready to go trying to
be here around the corner there
um I agree with what you've said Alex uh
the
platforms audiences uh reflected across
our audiences so men typically not as
engaged as women
especially across Facebook and as this
is only showing our social media
demographics but you're quite right that
we do take a multi-channel approach and
use a lot of other mediums as well
foreign
moving buffet
and as soon as you think you get a grip
on it it changes Direction it's like a
river and flood
um but it's fun
gone are those simple days of two radio
stations and one newspaper
I'm going back further
Oh no you're probably going back further
than I know I'm going a bit further than
you two newspapers morning and night
good Heavens wow I know
me Clark
just going back to the issue of the
toilet and Russell Square
um
so I noticed before that uh I wasn't
keen on it being a couple of years away
being that a very subjective Target
so just seeking some advice from Steve
or from Michael day
um whether that can be a more firmed up
commitment for me six months is as long
as it needs to be
um if a date then is my approach to that
to be a notice of motion that gives a
clear Direction I mean just trying to
seek out what you'd like
an Xbox I mean we've been at least two
years in the making already
and and numerous complaints that's what
I mean I might uh three each year I
might start and then pass over to the
Box yeah yeah we'll do it in six weeks
um look this is uh Parks have identified
this um our property team actually uh
the people that install and manage the
toilets across our reserves in public
spaces we can certainly pass your
direction on to our property team and it
could be brought back to the
infrastructure committee
um for a response to this question uh
We've certainly raised it based on the
feedback from last month with the
property team and
uh Passover to the Bosnia
thank you through yourself to you look
we've already got the question
um that's come through uh we'll take
that on board and we will report that
back through the infrastructure
committee on progress in relation to
that okay thank you
thank you any other items from in the
activities report
if not would somebody like to move that
we receive the report
and Council of Germany I'll put that all
in favor all right against
Carriage a penultimate item and public
is the receiving as a major laid out in
the minutes of the community well-being
fund committee public ones
recommendation there
would like to move
the party and Peter
any discussion I'll put that all in
favor all right against
Carrie uh before we go into public
excluded I'll take this opportunity to
pass on on behalf of council and prior
to an event on Thursday
uh councilors gratitude Steve for your
role as our group manager of leisure and
Recreation enrollment that you took up
late October early November post our
first lockdown which must have been and
I think you were just pleased to get out
of the house but
in in the last two and a half years
um the impact you've been able to make
with this Council has been significant
and appreciated
um it is a loss
for us but again for the new Council
that you're going to
and I think um part of your natural
progression within the sector but but
thank you and and all the best on our
behalf
councilors I'll move that we go into
public excluded to confirm the minutes
of the pre-excession of the community
wellbeing committee as for the reasons
as outlined
and sorry the major late item which is
the community well-being fund and
sorry who stuck behind up there Grant
and Barry thank you pop that all in
favor against Kerry to those that have
joined us on the live stream thank you
for your attention this afternoon